[Music]
this episode of real science is brought
to you by skillshare home to thousands
of classes that can teach you a new life
skill
550 million years ago the ocean was a
simple ecosystem full of reefs made by
bacteria and a gooey mat of microbes
that covered the ocean floor
creatures were simple often amorphous
none were yet predatory but within a few
million years this simple ecosystem
would disappear replaced by an ocean
full of diverse mobile and highly
effective animals the world's first
predators emerged during the cambrian
explosion 540 million years ago in the
form of giant shrimp-like creatures like
the anomalocaris which trapped its prey
in its mouth lined with hooks or the
five-eyed opa-binia which caught its
victims using a flexible clawed arm
attached to its head
soon the first fish emerged the jawless
egnatha of which two groups still
survived today the lampreys and the
hagfish and by 450 million years ago the
ocean was populated by the ancestor of
what is now the most fearsome predator
of the sea
sharks
the first modern sharks arrived in the
late devonian 370 million years ago
taking the iconic shape we know today
they were six feet long with a
streamlined body five to seven gill
slits and dorsal fins
soon sharks dominated the oceans the
carboniferous era was a period with some
of the most unique sharks that ever
existed
strange species like the stetho canthus
a shark with what looks like an anvil on
its head the eugenio dantida a shark
with a tooth whirl at the bottom of its
jaw and the falcodus a shark with a long
sharp horn on its head but these strange
iterations of the shark have long since
gone extinct the sharks that prevailed
were largely streamlined with a pointed
snout large pectoral and dorsal fins and
a strong crescent-shaped tail like the
great whites or the short fin mako
sharks like these have dominated the
seas for hundreds of millions of years
that is until evolution decided to take
a strange turn
around 20 million years ago evolution
created the newest shark to enter the
water arguably the strangest one of them
all
with a mallet-shaped head full of
sensory organs and eyes set on either
end the hammerhead is one of the most
recognizable and downright bizarre
looking animals on the earth their body
plan a drastic departure from the other
sharks that roam the sea
they are found in temperate and tropical
waters worldwide and can often be seen
in massive numbers as they migrate to
colder water
up to 6 meters long and weighing up to
450 kilograms hammerheads are a
formidable and dominant force across the
world's oceans
why only recently did shark evolution
take such a surprising turn making
something so different from the rest and
what does their odd-shaped head do that
gives hammerheads their evolutionary
edge
[Music]
the iconic hammer of the hammerhead
shark is called a cephalofoil and the
size of it varies from species to
species
it's easy to assume this weird shape is
a rubbery extension of flesh but it's
actually a flattened and stretched out
skull
the smallest cephalofoil is the modest
bonnet head also known as the shovelhead
the largest is the winghead shark whose
wing-like head is so big its width is
nearly 50 percent of its total body
length all other hammerheads fall
between these two extremes
and on the tip of all of the hammerhead
cephalofoils are their weird beady eyes
this configuration is a little baffling
being as spread out as they are it would
seem like each eye would see the world
independently with no overlap in each
eye's vision not something that would be
very helpful for a predator
the visible field for all creatures is
the expanse of space visible to them
without moving their eyes in humans our
forward-facing horizontal visual field
is around 190 degrees
our binocular vision where the vision of
each eye overlaps giving us depth
perception covers 120 horizontal degrees
in fact most predators have large
binocular fields to help quickly scan
the environment for prey an ability made
possible by having eyes that face
forward by contrast most prey animals
have eyes on the sides of their heads to
help them be aware of danger coming from
any direction
pigeons for example have a visual field
of around 310 degrees but a very narrow
binocular portion in the front you can
see this pattern throughout the animal
kingdom prey and predator species
distinguishable by eye position but when
you look at a hammerhead shark it's not
immediately obvious what's going on
there they are obviously predators but
its eyes are far apart and in a totally
unique configuration from all other
vertebrates does the weird shape of the
hammerhead hurt or help their vision and
thus their predatory ability
in 2009 researchers started to get to
the bottom of it
they compared the visual fields of three
hammerhead shark species to two sharks
with a more typical head morphology to
see which type of shark body plan offers
a more enhanced binocular field all
sharks in the study had a full 360
vertical visual field with similar
vertical binocular overlaps the
hammerheads didn't really differ here
but when looking at the horizontal
visual field the differences were
profound
the total monocular visual fields ranged
from 308 to 340 degrees with the
hammerheads on the upper end and when
comparing binocular field of view the
hammerheads were the clear winners the
lemon shark had a mere 10 degrees of
binocular overlap the black nose just
11.
the modest bonnet head had a bit more
with 13 and the scalloped hammerhead had
32 degrees of overlap and the winghead
shark the one with the widest head had
48 degrees of binocular overlap nearly
four times that of the typical sharks
it's clear then that the binocular
overlaps in hammerheads increases as the
width of the head increases
this gives them an advantage when
hunting for prey by giving them
exceptional depth perception out of all
the sharks they have the clearest view
of the underwater world and it shows
hammerheads are some of the most
effective predators among the sharks
easily catching and devouring stingrays
octopuses and even other sharks this
alone may have been enough to influence
the evolution of the hammerhead
cephalofoil but the long flat shape of
the head does more than give the shark
better vision it also gives the
hammerhead unique hydrodynamics found
nowhere else in the animal kingdom
when you think of agility and speed in
the ocean you think of animals like mako
sharks or bottlenose dolphins animals
with a streamlined pointed nose that
cuts through the water but a hammerhead
shark is basically the opposite of that
it's like an airplane with a wing
attached to its front hammerheads have
to use much more energy than other
normal shark species just to swim
because of the increased drag it's a lot
of work to push that thing around
so the obvious question is why would
nature do this
what benefit does this give to the
hammerhead if any
elasmobranks like the sharks and rays
don't have a swim bladder so they have
to constantly swim to avoid sinking to
the bottom
so for a long time it was thought that
the cephalofoil indeed acts like a wing
producing lift forces that help the
hammerhead stay vertically positioned in
the water column
this theory seems to make sense when you
compare the cephalofoil to an airplane
wing the hammerhead hammer looks just
like one the structure's technical name
cephalofoil even means head wing
it's easy to assume then that the flow
of water over the cephalofoil works just
like the flow of air over a wing
to test this theory researchers laser
scanned the heads of eight species of
hammerhead each digitized head was then
placed in a virtual underwater
environment allowing them to measure
water pressure drag and flow they then
did the same for a few shark species
with more typical pointy heads and
surprisingly they found that the
cephalofoil does not create lift when
the shark is swimming in a regular
forward motion but when the head is
tilted up or down strong forces quickly
come into play
when the angle of attack changes the
shark can rapidly ascend or descend the
hammer is not for lift but for
maneuverability and this type of motion
is essential for how the hammerhead
hunts
unlike mako sharks that chase down prey
in long pursuits hammerheads swim just
above the sand looking for bottom
dwelling prey once detected these prey
animals like stingrays or squid will
erratically dart away to escape
zigzagging up down left right and the
hammerhead follows suit supporting this
hypothesis is the winghead shark who has
the biggest head of all the hammerheads
compared to its body it has the largest
amount of drag but also shows the
greatest change in lift as the attack
angle changes
of all the hammerheads it has the best
maneuverability
and when you look at its diet you can
see why evolution would create something
so extreme
most hammerheads eat crabs or stingrays
creatures that are quick but not known
for their sheer agility but the wing
head diet consists of about 93
teleost fishes like herrings which are
very fast and very agile
the cephalofoil gives the hammerheads an
agility unmatched in the world of sharks
allowing them to fill an ecological
niche that other sharks cannot but on
top of this agility hammerheads possess
a sixth sense something which we have no
equivalent to their ability to detect
minute and invisible electric fields in
the water
[Music]
the underwater world for us is distorted
our vision blurred our hearing muffled
we can immediately tell that the ocean
is not where we belong
but on top of our senses becoming out of
whack there is so much more going on
under the waves than we could ever
perceive a world of stimuli that we
can't pick up on at all a world of
electricity
electroreception is a sixth sense to
many aquatic creatures it's an ability
to detect the electrical fields that
permeate the water giving navigational
cues and information about the location
of prey
in fact it's observed almost exclusively
in aquatic animals since water is a much
better conductor of electricity than air
many members of the elasmobrank fish
family share this trait but shark's
electro-reception abilities are the most
finely tuned
sharks receive tiny electrical signals
from their environment via a series of
pores peppered over their heads
these pores are distributed in discrete
patterns varying somewhat among the
elasmobrank species in this picture of a
great white shark you can see the
clusters of pores around its eyes and
nostrils
these pores are filled with an
electrically conductive jelly and lead
to tiny bulbous cells called ampolae of
lorenzini and this is the key to their
amazing power
all animals generate electricity around
them as their muscles contract in
movement and their heartbeats and this
current radiates away from them in the
water when these electrical currents
travel towards the shark and through the
jelly they stimulate cilia hair-like
projections on the amplia which then
trigger the sensory neurons
this then triggers neurotransmitters in
the shark's brains which tells them they
are close to something alive
this sense works even when the
conditions underwater render the five
other common senses sight smell taste
touch and hearing useless
it works in turbulent water in total
darkness and even when prey are hidden
beneath the sand and for the hammerheads
this sense is even more extreme
with a wider head hammerheads have a
greater number of electrosensory pores
the pores are also located over a
broader area which increases the surface
area that the head can sample and thus
increases the probability of a prey
encounter
so when the hammerhead swims above the
sand it waves its head like a metal
detector looking for treasure its
treasure being a buried stingray and the
sensitivity of this metal detector head
is profound
researchers found that newborn
bonnethead sharks can detect electric
fields less than one nanovolt per square
centimeter
this is around the equivalent to the
intensity of a voltage gradient that
would be created in the sea by
connecting one end of a 1.5 volt double
a battery to the long island sound and
the other end in the waters off of
florida theoretically a shark swimming
between these places could tell when the
battery was switched on or off
such incredible electrical sensitivity
is over 5 million times greater than
anything we could ever feel even our
best technology struggles to detect
something that minute
and it's likely the most powerful
electrical sensing in the animal kingdom
we often think of the weirdest
cartoonist animals being things of the
past creatures that were giant strange
or sinister but hammerheads show us that
evolution is never finished what seems
illogical or even detrimental to an
animal's survival can be the key to them
fitting into a very specific
environmental niche
what else will appear on earth in the
next 50 or 100 million years what will
sharks look like given that much time
some reef shark species have recently
evolved the ability to walk even above
the water at low tide
other species have recently been
discovered to glow in the dark
others can live in fresh water in
addition to salt water
what else does the future hold for
sharks like the hammerheads
it's hard to speculate but the
possibilities are endless
sharks have dominated the seas since the
end cretaceous and as a group have
survived all five mass extinctions so
far in large part due to their ability
to fill many varying ecological niches
but the hammerheads as the newest
species of shark have not yet faced such
an event that is until now
many believe we're currently living
through the sixth mass extinction due to
human activity and sharks especially the
hammerheads are among the most at risk
one study in australia reported that 80
of scalloped hammerheads have been lost
they're threatened by commercial fishing
mainly for the shark fin trade where the
fins are cut off and the rest of the
body is discarded their numbers like
many sharks are dwindling and if we as a
species aren't careful we may never get
to see what the future holds for such
incredible creatures
being able to talk about the science and
conservation subjects near and dear to
my heart on a platform with such a wide
audience is something i once could only
have dreamed about after finishing
college i knew that science
communication was my passion i just
needed to find a way to make that my
career working with real engineering and
then starting this channel made that
dream a reality by growing my video
making skills and then learning how the
youtube world works i've been able to
create videos that i deeply care about
while also building a business one of
the most common questions i get is how
to start a youtube channel everyone has
a slightly different path to success on
youtube but there are a few pillars of
knowledge that will definitely help you
get there if you want to dive into this
endeavor i highly recommend marquez
brownlee's new course on skillshare
called youtube success script shoot and
edit with
mkbhd marquez will take you through step
by step how he makes his tech youtube
videos a creative process that can be
applied to any subject on youtube
whether you're interested in making
videos about tech science fashion or
nature it will inspire you to get your
idea off the ground and break it down so
it's not so overwhelming in the course
he explains the whole process from
choosing a topic and scripting it to
filming to editing to uploading it to
growing your channel he gives you
insight to how the behind the scenes
analytics work on youtube and how to
interpret and leverage those tools to
your benefit this is just one of many
courses on skillshare that can help you
build a youtube channel skillshare is an
online learning community with thousands
of inspiring classes for creative and
curious people it's curated specifically
for learning meaning there are no
distracting ads and it's less than ten
dollars a month with an annual
subscription but the first thousand
people to sign up with the link in the
description we'll get a free trial of
skillshare premium so you can dive into
classes about video editing animation or
graphic design all skills that are super
useful for making videos
there's no risk in trying it out and
getting your creativity flowing or
getting that idea you've had forever
finally off the ground
[Music]
you